اذا نحن في هذا اليوم الس 16س عشر بعد
المئه من الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه ولعلي
انطلق من تصريح لوزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
نقلته يدعوت احرنوت يقول بان اسرائيل
ستحكم غزه عسكريا وليس مدنيا تصريح له
دلالات واكيد تبعات وياتي ربما بعد ما تم
تداوله عن نيه اسرائيل في انشاء نوعا ما
منطقه عازله على طول حدود غزه ولعل
التطورات اللافته خصوصا في المنطقه
الشماليه وايضا حاله الاشتباك القائمه في
المناطق الجنوبيه والمناطق الوسطى ربما
تطرح اكثر من تساؤل متعلقه بهذا التصريح
لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه الشماليه ولعل
العواجل التي نقلناها على الجزيره تتحدث
عن نفسها من خلال عمليات استهداف مكثفه
لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعمليه قصف مكثف
هذا القصف بالاساس كان في المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه كان هنا حديث كان
هناك حديث لمراسلنا ان على ان هذا القصف
بالاساس طال شرق حي الزيتون في المناطق
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه لكن القصف ايضا طال
عددا من المناطق هناك قد تابعنا اعلان عن
قصف لمنطقه جباليا ولكن ايضا عن اشتباكات
وايضا عمليات قصف
للمناطق الشماليه الغربيه لغزه وتحديدا
احياء الشيخ رضوان و ايضا حي النصر في هذه
المنطقه وايضا حي الشاطئ اذا تطورات لافته
في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه ولكن ايضا في
المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه وتحديدا تل
الهواء هذه المحاور كما نلاحظ تعود لها
عمليه القصف المكثف ولكن ايضا حديث عن
اشتباكات تخوضها المقاومه تحديدا على
مستوى المحاور الشماليه الغربيه وايضا
الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه عمليه قصف
مكثفه لا تختلف عنها ايضا المنطقه الوسطى
حيث كان مراسلنا ايضا قد تحدث عن عمليه
قصف مكثفه هنا لمخيم النصيرات لكن سرايا
القدس كانت قد تحدثت عن عملي استهداف
لاليات عسكريه هنا في حي المغازي وذلك
بقذائف مضاده للدروع ولعل المغازي يعود
دوما الى الواجهه بالنظر الى التطورات
التي شاهدها في الايام القادمه من خلال
اشتباكات عنيفه خاضتها المقاومه مع قوات
جيش الاحتلال لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه
وتحديدا في محاور الاشتباك ومحاور
الاستهداف نحن نتحدث بالاساس عن هذه
المناطق المناطق الغربيه وايضا المناطق
الجنوبيه من مدينه خان يونس اخر الاخبار
تتحدث على ان عمليات الاستهداف وعمليات
القصف بالاساس تتم هنا في الم المناطق
الشماليه لمدينه خان يونس لو ذهبنا الى
الخريطه باكثر تفصيل لعل محاور الاستهداف
والاشتباك بالاساس هو ما يمكن تسميته
بحصار المستشفيات نشير بالاساس الى هذين
المستشفيين مستشفى الامل ومستشفى ناصر
الذين تعرضا الى عمليه قصف اسرائيليه
مكثفه وفي ظل وجود نحو 3000 من النازحين
خصوصا في مستشفى ناصر اذا تطورات لافته
ليله على جبهات الجنوب لكن اللافت هو هذا
التصعيد في المنطقه الشماليه